goku luffy you son of a [ __ ]
goku or luffy new school or old school
dragon ball or one piece both of these
franchises have at one time order their
carriage shown and jump on their
respective backs both have set records
in their time and both are recognized
the world over
as juggernauts in their industry but
which one is better and
moreover what makes me qualified enough
to answer that question
well over the course of my career on
youtube i've extensively covered the
dragon ball franchise dissecting its
themes characters and plot structures
and if you were to have asked me which
one i preferred one year ago i would
have said without hesitation akira
toriyama's dragon ball however over the
last year
something happened what you can't leave
it there
[ __ ] you during 2020 i dedicated over
half a year of my life to blitzing my
way through
over 1 000 chapters of eight year old's
one piece arcs
characters and themes accordingly and if
you've seen even one part of that long
series you'll no doubt have heard me say
one piece's alabaster arc is the best
manga experience i've had in my entire
life my favorite installment so far best
arc one piece has
okay look i know i say that all the time
but it is the best saga for sure
okay yeah this act was the best like
it's absolutely incredible
however now that i've stepped away from
the series and marinated on the topic
for a time
i knew that this video would make for an
interesting comparison to explore
so grab some food sit back and get ready
to argue in the comments section because
today
i will be comparing two of the most
legendary shonen stories to have ever
made their way to the west
today i try to answer the age-old
question which is better
one piece or dragon ball
[Music]
in the red corner a returning champion
standing strong with 519 chapters to its
name
alongside its main man g that dons the
orange key
we have akira toriyama's 1980s martial
arts adventure manga
dragon ball and in the blue corner the
current reigning champion with a
remarkable 1005 chapters and counting to
its name
alongside the straw hat that's all that
we have eight cheer orders
modern high-seas adventure manga one
piece
which is better well first of all we
gotta figure out what does
better mean one property could have
better characters while another has
better visuals or story or sales etc so
in order to determine which of these
sits atop this mountain for me
i have to devise a list of topics for
each franchise to battle within so let's
begin
sales where better to start this
entirely subjective contest than with an
objective metric
total worldwide manga sales figures
manga sales are something that are
easily measured and
in this instance the numbers do not lie
one piece
comfortably sits atop this mountain as
the best-selling manga series
ever created however it did so after
dethroning dragon ball who had up until
that point been at the top spot for well
over a decade
and even as i write this dragon ball
despite having finished in 1996
is still in the number two spot right
beneath one piece
but you might be thinking one piece has
been in serialization for over 20 years
and that's sort of an unfair advantage
if you consider the fact that dragon
ball's lifespan was only 11. so
in other words in order to see which was
truly the best seller of its time
let's see how 11 years of one piece
sales stack up when compared to the 11
years
of dragon balls and the results to this
were honestly
shocking mostly because no one seems to
know
when one piece overtook dragon ball this
monumentally important moment in pop
culture history
seems to have been lost to the webs of
time people always say
one piece is the highest selling manga
and that it overtook dragon ball to
achieve that but
no one seems to know when it happened it
just
happened sometime vaguely between 2005
and 2015 i guess
this wasn't good enough to answer which
sold more and to be honest at this point
i wanted to try to figure this out for
the internet and
i did find an answer eventually this
took
over five hours of research through
weird translation websites the asking of
admins of various fan sites and
i even scoured through the web for any
articles on the topic
dating back as far as 2010 and spoiler
alert there weren't any
thanks to the weird japanese translation
website i was able to learn that by the
year 2000 dragonball had sold over 126
million copies of its manga
this means that it had sold less than
that by the time it ended in 1996
and since one piece started in 1997 now
all i needed to do was find the late
2000s total worldwide sales figures for
one piece
this proved to be near impossible there
was an
ocean of articles talking about
seemingly every other achievement or
milestone that one piece attained but
not
the achievement for some reason no one
was talking about this
i had honestly no idea why no one ever
documented this information for easy to
find consumption online
in my despair as a last-ditch effort i
sent out a tweet to all of you
to be frank i was ready to scrap the
video entirely
but then amidst the dozens of
questionable sources sent my way
one very old web domain was submitted it
was from 2008
exactly 11 years after one piece was
released
hence shaking in anticipation i
frantically scroll down the page past
all the useless information
and then out of the corner of my eye i
saw it i swear if my fiance wasn't
sitting right next to me as i write this
i tell you all that this was the single
most beautiful thing
i'd ever seen in my life and i have this
fine individual to thank
some heroes don't wear capes thank you
at boise bird
you're doing god's work with this vital
missing piece of the puzzle
i could then confirm i think perhaps for
the first time on youtube it feels like
and definitively say
that one piece dethroned dragon ball in
2009
but more importantly not only has one
piece sold more than dragon ball
but it also did so in a much shorter
span of time in 11 years dragon ball
managed to sell somewhere under 126
million copies
and in that same time one piece sold 140
million
odds are you heard of here first folks
the first point goes to one piece
the story dragon ball and one piece are
both kings of the shonen realm but
there's only room for one
true king in terms of story so what
makes a good
shonen story the answer for me it's
growth
whether that be through high seas
adventure or fighting across the galaxy
shonen predominantly i think is best
described as growth through
conflict and while physical conflict
often takes the lead within these
narratives and shown in storytelling
they are stories first and foremost so
how does one piece measure up to dragon
ball in that respect
dragon ball's narrative remains largely
straightforward with its moments of
interest coming from character
interactions and choices
it explores interesting themes through
characters like goku vegeta piccolo and
gohan among many others and has produced
some of the cornerstone moments in anime
culture as a whole for me the strongest
stretch in the series spans from the
23rd tenkaichi budokai
up until the climax to the frieza and
goku fight there are a lot of great
moments both before
and after this but for me the writing in
the series was always at its strongest
during this portion the dialogue was
quippy
the motivations were strong and it's one
brilliant and iconic scene
after the next however with that said
one piece has been ongoing for over 20
years and is still producing top tier
material today i'm even of the opinion
that the current arc of one piece 1 0 is
in the running for the best arc the
series
has ever produced having only now
recently looked back over the reviews i
made for one piece it's remarkable how
often the show would surprise me and
how brilliant oda is for planting seeds
and structuring how his story will grow
long
into the future toriyama famously did
not do this with dragon ball
instead opting to make it up as he went
one piece does have its low points but
even taking them into consideration
putting them
side by side there's way way more going
on on a narrative level
in the world oda created i love dragon
ball story but in this case it's not
even close
this is to take nothing away from dragon
ball as it did a lot of amazing things
but one piece has set
a whole new standard and because of this
i gotta give the point to one piece
the visuals while the story makes up a
massive portion of most shonen
many are often defined by the reception
to their action set pieces and visuals
and now that i've become a reviewer of
sorts one of my biggest fears when
picking up a new manga to critique is
that its layouts and artwork will prove
to be less helpful and more of an
obstruction
standing in the way of me understanding
the story manga is a visual medium first
and foremost and if you don't make use
of the visuals you may as well have
written a book in my opinion people read
their manga for vastly different reasons
however for me
i hold paneling clarity and art in
extremely high regard
and i've mentioned this numerous times
in almost all of my reviews
dragon ball is for me a gold standard in
this department
if you haven't read dragon ball and only
watched it i highly recommend opening a
random page from the series to observe
how easy it is to get sucked into it
while akira toriyama wasn't as stand out
as one piece on a narrative level from a
visual and layout standpoint
i'd consider akira toriyama a genius the
sense of suspense
energy rhythm and pacing he managed to
inject into his work is something i miss
most from modern manga and while hero
odd is paneling particularly towards the
beginning was great as the series went
on the panels instead of enhancing the
story became more and more of an
obstacle for me that got in the way of
engaging with the story during many
sections of its serialization and let it
be known that this isn't a bias for
dragon ball shining through here either
while i heavily praise the original run
of dragon ball for its layouts i also
heavily criticized dragon ball super's
manga
as well as recognized the deterioration
in layouts towards the end of the series
in the buu saga however even taking
all of that into consideration much the
same way it wasn't a contest for one
piece in the story department dragon
ball
easily takes a point in this round i
love one piece
but dragon ball even outside of this
contest is still one of the most
superbly laid out mangas i've ever in my
life
read through
[Music]
main characters one of the most
surprising aspects for me while i was
writing this video was how definitive i
felt about
almost every topic when it came to sales
story and visuals
all of these aspects i had come to a
conclusion on prior i just needed to
formulate my thoughts more clearly on
them however this one was by far the
most difficult section to both
articulate my feelings on and ultimately
make a decision for this is probably due
to the nostalgic nature i hold dragon
ball in and how impressive and likable i
found one piece to be last year but
i had to make a decision and with a
heavy conflicted heart i have to give
this one to one pieces
luffy but before you set my channel on
fire allow me to explain myself
one piece is directly inspired by akira
toriyama's dragon ball and
because of this both luffy and goku
share a ton
of traits in common with each other both
from the energy they exhibit in pursuing
their goals to their tenacity and their
love for their friends they definitely
have more in common than they have
aspects that are distinct if you ask me
however in the small ways that they are
different i managed to formulate
my decision through interviews akira
toriyama has come out in saying that a
fundamental piece of goku's personality
that people
often don't recognize is the small but
very present poison in his character
this is the aspect of goku's personality
that will lead him to pursue the story
in really fun and interesting ways
however it will also
oftentimes lead him to pursue dangerous
circumstances in lieu of a much more
safe and stable life for his family and
friends he will give a senzu bean to
cell he will stay dead for longer to get
more training in he will routinely leave
and alienate himself from his family
and friends in search of better fights
the ending to dragon ball's original run
while i thought it was fitting for the
series still felt strange to discover
that goku didn't keep in touch with
almost anyone in his life
and for me that aspect of his
personality can be frustrating
or disillusioning at times luffy on the
other hand doesn't share this trait at
all
instead motivated to keep his friends
safe and to reach his goal too
and i think if you were to ask luffy to
choose between never seeing his friends
again
and becoming king of the pirates he'd
make the decision without even thinking
however when it comes to goku
if you asked him to choose between
seeing his friends again and a fight
with the strongest person in the
universe i really think you'd have to
think about it for a second
as a character goku i think is
phenomenal and offers a nuance that
still escapes many of the modern writers
today in super and its manga
however on numerous occasions luffy has
demonstrated a straightforward purity
that has moved me to tears
more times than i care to count and for
that reason as well as what i've said
here i have to give the point
to luffy and one piece the supporting
characters
unlike the last section this one was
actually quite easy dragon ball has not
only some terrific supporting characters
but also has some of my favorite
characters in all of fiction
piccolo bulma gohan vegeta ten shinhan
mr satan all of these are iconic in
their own way and offer vastly different
dynamics to the story at large however
dragon ball is let down in one
fundamental aspect and that's that the
supporting cast a lot of the time either
becomes irrelevant
or they become something that offers
less utility within the ever-changing
story
one piece on the other hand has arcs of
story dedicated to each of the straw hat
pirates as luffy meets and befriends all
of them in addition to that
hero oda goes to tremendous links to not
only include these characters
consistently but
also makes them essential and
fundamental aspects to the victories
luffy ultimately achieves in them
over 1 000 chapters later and characters
like zoro nami usaf and sanji
are all still just as crucial today as
they were back then perhaps even more so
and that is something i can absolutely
not say for the likes of yamcha
tenshinhan and
piccolo unfortunately this one goes to
one piece i think i like some of the
side characters a little more in dragon
ball but
overall one piece dominates this section
the villains where one piece's conflicts
are strongly defined and spawned from
how luffy and his crew deal with the
circumstances brought on by their
respective villains
dragon ball is practically defined by
its villains with each subsequent thread
even informing the name of that given
saga of the story the saiyan saga the
frieza saga the cell saga etc one piece
has some amazing antagonists and
villains like blackbeard and the world
government but those are still
very much unknown quantities at this
moment so for that reason i will omit
them in this conversation however even
if i were to include them
in my decision it's still the same my
favorite villains from the world of one
piece are the likes of arlon
inel crocodile and dolflamingo these are
all great in their own respects but when
i compare them to the likes of piccolo
vegeta frieza and cell
a clearer picture starts to emerge one
piece of villains a lot of the time are
quite complex and
offer a lot in the way of their
narrative however if i go off which i
would be more excited to see crocodile
or frieza inel or vegeta
in my opinion it's a no-brainer
obviously like everything else it all
boils down to personal preference but in
my opinion the point has to go to dragon
ball for having the better villains
cultural impact when it comes to
domestic japanese cultural impact
without question one piece
is king in 2015 i went to japan with my
friends to see the place for the very
first time
and upon arriving i was absolutely blown
away by how much one-piece stuff there
was
everywhere other friends of mine have
traveled to the middle of nowhere rural
japan and have found figurines of luffy
laying around
to say one piece is everywhere in japan
is like saying there are a couple of
trees in the amazon it's a massive
understatement however when we leave the
sheltered shores in the land of the
rising sun and venture into the wider
world
dragon ball squashes one piece
[Applause]
to help put into perspective dragon ball
is so impossibly ubiquitous globally
that the only other japanese properties
to do better than it on a world stage
are the likes of hello kitty mario and
pokemon there's a reason why goku was
chosen as the main ambassador for the
2020 olympic games over the likes of
naruto sailor moon mario and
even luffy himself the broad and
far-reaching appeal of the dragon ball
franchise is something that can be felt
the world over whether it be referenced
in popular internet videos
parades american cartoons rap lyrics or
even as i said
the olympic games both from an optics
and sales perspective dragon ball gets
the definitive win
in the cultural impact section
accessibility one of the drawbacks to
how strong the one piece story is is how
involved it can be
which is often the reason why many are
afraid to jump into the adventure at
first
while i was working on reviewing the
series one of the main complaints i
heard was how daunting of an enterprise
starting and jumping into one piece can
be
it's fantastically well structured and
paced however i can see where they are
coming from in some respects but funnily
enough while dragon ball
is also another long-running anime and
manga i
never heard that same complaint touted
for them on the contrary
dragon ball story is touted as being
incredibly simple and easy to follow
along with at any point in time and i
think that's one of the biggest secrets
to its success
one can jump in anywhere in the story
and have a great time whereas in one
piece
a lot of the events are very much plot
driven and satisfying moments depend
heavily on factors that were established
earlier in the story
think arlang park with nami that scene
with luffy wouldn't hit
nearly as hard if you didn't already
know what happened in the story prior
however
in the case of dragon ball the standoff
with vegeta is so simple to understand
that hopping on becomes possible for
both the young and old alike
my dad got caught up in it and he didn't
even know what anime was
and it was during this time too when i
first started watching the series
like most people in the west i jumped in
halfway through the series and
loved it all the same some of you out
there might be saying that accessibility
isn't important however i think it's
hard to discredit it because
in reality how accessible something is
plays a large role into its ultimate
success in connecting with people around
the world and when you compare dragon
ball's wide appeal worldwide with one
pieces it becomes obvious which one wins
this section
dragon ball takes the point here and
with that we have a tie
four points for dragon ball and four
points for one piece
this can't end in a tie and so i needed
a tie break i decided to instead of
creating another topic for these guys to
be compared in earlier this week i
decided to post two polls to see
which one you all preferred one on my
twitter and another
on my youtube channel and between them
over 100
000 votes were cast by fans across the
globe and the winner was
one piece one piece wins this time but i
think that's gonna be something that's
ever changing between them
this is after all a property that has
both an anime and manga
currently in circulation however even in
saying that for these two titans of the
industry to contend so feverishly with
one another shouldn't be held as a
slight to either but
instead a testament to how fantastic and
fundamentally brilliant both of these
franchises truly are and how much
everyone seems to love and respect them
in the past i've gone on the record
during various podcasts stating that i
think that comparing these is
almost impossible that they're just too
different and while on some level are
similar and occupy the same industry
both try to achieve extremely different
things with vastly different approaches
in design philosophy but i decided to
ignore that and make this video because
i thought it might be fun and in the end
one piece won
thanks to the popularity it has to this
day however 50 years ago
this was the cutting edge standard for
japanese storytelling
and today it looks like this our
standards for what qualifies as
better are constantly changing but it
raises an interesting question i think
for me to leave you all with today in 25
years
after one piece is finished will it
still be as popular as it is now
will it have the same staying power that
dragon ball has proven to have
only time will tell but until then i've
been told not mark
and thank you all so much for watching
[Music]